what I hope to do in this video is a
proof of the famous and useful and
somewhat elegant and sometimes infamous
chain rule and if you've been following
some of the videos on differentiability
implies continuity and what happens to a
continuous function is our change in X
if X is our independent variable as that
gets down as that approaches zero how
the change in our function approaches
zero then this proof is actually
surprisingly straightforward so let's
just get to it this is just one of many
proofs of the chain rule so the chain
rule tells us that if Y Y is a function
of U which is a function of X and we
want to figure out the derivative of
this so we want to differentiate this
with respect to X so we're going to
differentiate this with respect to X we
could write this as the derivative of Y
with respect to X which is going to be
equal to the derivative of Y with
respect to U times the derivative of U
with respect to X this is what the chain
rule tells us but how do we actually go
about proving it well we just have to
remind ourselves that the derivative of
Y with respect to X the derivative of Y
with respect to X is equal to the limit
as Delta X approaches zero of change in
Y over change in X now we can do a
little bit of algebraic manipulation
here to introduce a change in U so let's
do that so this is going to be the same
thing as the limit as Delta X approaches
zero and I'm going to rewrite this part
right over here I'm going to essentially
divide and multiply by a change in U so
I can rewrite this as Delta Y over Delta
u times Delta u ty UPS times Delta u
over Delta X change in Y over change in
u times changing u over change in X
and you can see this is just going to be
numbers here so our change in you this
would cancel with that and you'd be left
with change in Y over change in X which
is exactly what we had here so nothing
nothing earth-shattering
just yet but what's this going to be
equal to what's this going to be equal
to well the limit of the product is the
same thing as the product of the limits
so this is going to be the same thing as
the limit as Delta X approaches 0 of
colour-coded of this stuff of Delta Y
over Delta u times maybe I'll put
parentheses around it x times the limit
the limit as Delta X approaches 0 Delta
X approaches 0 of this business so I put
some parentheses around it Delta u over
Delta X so what does this simplify to
well this right over here this is the
definition and we're assuming in order
for this to even be true we have to
assume that U and Y are differentiable
at X so we assume in order for this to
be true we're assuming we're assuming y
comma u are differentiable are
differentiable are differentiable at X
and remember also if they're
differentiable at X that means they're
continuous in X but if u is
differentiable at X then this limit
exists and this is the derivative of
this is u prime of X or d u DX so this
right over here we can rewrite as d u DX
I think you see where this is going now
this right over here just looking at it
the way this written it-- right here we
can't quite yet call this dy D u because
this is the limit as Delta X approaches
0 not the limit as Delta u approaches 0
but we just have to remind ourselves the
results from probably the previous video
depending on how your
watching it which is if we have a
function you that is continuous at a
point that as Delta X approaches 0 Delta
u approaches 0 so we can actually
rewrite this we can wreak an rewrite
this right over here instead of saying
Delta X approaches 0 that's just going
to have the effect because U is
differentiable at X which means it's
continuous at X that means that Delta U
is going to approach zero as our change
in X gets smaller and smaller and
smaller our change in U is going to get
smaller and smaller and smaller so we
can rewrite this as our change in U
approaches 0 and when we rewrite it like
that well then this is just dy D U this
is just dy the derivative of Y with
respect to U so just like that if we
assume Y is and u are differentiable at
X or you could say that Y is a function
of U which is a function of X we've just
shown in fairly simple algebra here and
using some assumptions about
differentiability and continuity that it
is indeed the case that the derivative
of Y with respect to X is equal to the
derivative of the Y with respect to U
times the derivative of U with respect
to X hopefully you find that convincing